[Music]
and relationship guarantee news oh my
love the secrets to love tell me how do
you do it
salt we'll find out submitted by love
from an Afghan Oh Nadine Nadine family a
Swedish hotel chain is offering a refund
to couple to get divorce within one year
of staying at one of us hotels
oh that's very nice so if you're
planning to have a divorce you should
stay there because you'll get a free
stay just have a little vacation before
you have a divorce
or is there like a limit to how many
days don't applaud you days yeah because
like is there to stay there for like I
don't know yeah I tell me tonight babe
Oh two nights a two nights days I don't
think your plan would've worked you
would get two nights free I'll just stay
three gets three nights for the price of
one
yeah so there's this a hotel called the
countryside hotel group and the reason
why they're offering this refund is
because they want couples to really work
on their relationships they don't want a
couple of to get divorced obviously and
so they're saying that they're offering
this relationship guarantee on mini
breaks at their hotels so they're saying
that let's say you stay there with your
partner which by the way there's
requirements you have to have proof you
were married before your stay and you
have to make sure that you book only one
room in a state in that same room
together it can't be like loophole so
they're paying that if you stay at their
one of themselves and you get divorces
in one year then that's when they'll
reimburse you two nights stay because
they want people making work out so if
your wife is beating you please come to
our hotel and try to work it out because
we don't want people to divorce we want
you to stay together she could stop
beating in yeah record that maybe but
what if she's being him inside the hotel
too
you want to encourage that shift this
guess what happens they get those two
net 200 yes Brandon Lewis [ __ ] well he
gets a black guy I mean what's going to
happen regardless if they're in the
hotel room or not CCC consistent might
as well do it in a beautiful place you
know yeah you're gonna get your ass
kicked by your wife let it be a week on
clean sheets nice furniture but someone
else has to go you can get your ass beat
stress-free yep cuz I hate getting my
ass beat and you can't do nothing no I
hate it when I ask feedbacks auditions
to worry about Ana laundry to do and
it's a filthy house that happened I
haven't gotten my oil change you know
like they would ask me like [ __ ] I
forgot to change the oil but then if you
have nothing to worry about you're on
vacation going to ask me it's way more
pleasure it is cool you can focus on the
pain you know what I've been looking
forward to horseback riding the next day
so even though I'm getting my ass beat
I'll be like at least there's horses
tomorrow is there like a really high
divorce rate over there is that one good
question where is this yeah you didn't
even on three please I'm not sure if I
have a higher divorce probably not they
got idea why they probably do can that
furniture [ __ ] fall apart right away
no I thought about it
particleboard [ __ ] couple spa begins a
big-ass fights turn a villain right
[ __ ] IKEA ending relationships that's
a real test for relationship and
friendship like just any relationship
what if you build furniture together
helping out are you guys past the IKEA
test that's the true testament I know I
know Julia and I are solid yeah yeah
we're solid mm-hmm well can did we ever
build anything like rah rah were shaky
not a very old building with any person
I build all Edgar everything we built
Sofia remember when we first oh yeah
we're hot girl yeah we don't okay first
dresser ever oh we did we're good -
feels like it - oh my god butcher truck
camper thing together don't something
with it we're sorry
yeah that was that was almost harder
than IKEA dog it will sizes okay no we
were watching YouTube tutorials while
trying to [ __ ] build that
on it like like timeline
I don't know PI at least a good hour to
I think like I never buy oxygen after
she'll attack me up like an hour ready
yeah she's like hey I need help everyone
that went outside before we spend our
hour together okay we built the [ __ ]
set side Taylor designed the same for
that but you said no I can't or that
it's not like that was hard
that was hard there were solid I don't
know why you just building unit I do me
yeah they're right yeah but I mean with
TIF I feel like we billion yeah my
nervous guy you don't figure it out for
you I don't this for you yeah with your
roommate that's what I'm saying like can
we're sorry did we do the wall yeah yeah
gun we did that together and Julian why
didn't we do together well you know what
so if you guys have stuff to build I'm
down I love building stuff yeah I feel
like Julia's more but destroyed in a
building I build a lot of stuff in my
room but my semi table the desk drawer
is my bed frame my shelves I did a lot
of stuff not really still work of course
Gary Coxe I picture you like walking in
your room and be real clumsy and just
like knocking [ __ ] over like making
bookshelves and is that cancellous drink
that's not so you're a bull Julian you
should just get everything velcro to the
floor even like your bottles just don't
call everything onto the desk like no
matter what you should be one of hog
dare you tell oh I am full of finesse
okay what is she so smooth anyways back
to this hotel I think this will work
no um today we gonna solve [ __ ] years
of drama [ __ ] if I agree with that
but I also feel like once you remove
yourself from like the mundane and the
routine and then you spend some time
away from all the life's distractions I
feel like to turn yeah the quality I
feel like that's when at least you can
start kind of scratching the surface you
know so it probably won't fix it but it
could be the beginning of a rebuild you
just do it often enough I think this
probably this campaign is just for like
to remind people to get out like to get
out of the mundane but once a year once
every six months is not enough so like
you got to try to do it once a month or
whatever once every two weeks take out
that little bit of time no because we
even don't we don't really spend quality
time once in a while I gotta remember
you still got a vagina yeah more couples
what does that mean hmm like what does
it mean you remember she has images well
because I mean like when you know like
well we all work with each other and
then we also are in a relationship with
someone that we work with and when
they're like your business partner or
when they're over you got a working
relationship you're not sexually
harassing them all day you're not
thinking about how am I gonna get into
that vagina you're thinking man you
[ __ ] up on this one thing and well no
I [ __ ] up on this one in it or they
you know you're just working on [ __ ]
you're not thinking about how you're
gonna [ __ ] each other you thinking about
where you [ __ ] up on this isn't you
know that's great and when you do it
you're like oh oh yeah yeah we're like
back to see making babies like that's
what we got here riding children anytime
soon don't start
oh but like that you know what I mean
like you you go oh yeah we're just we're
not we don't get together because we
work well like that as a business
relationship yeah after we took our
after we took our like vacation to
Europe and stuff when we came back she
says wow you're kind of hot I told you
all about and that's when you made that
baby
they were hey hang out and go to parties
like what the [ __ ] I don't remember this
it's weird cuz the role switch yeah a
tennis you're like damn it's [ __ ]
annoying assistant man goddamn it's
always on my [ __ ] case or like oh I
feel like I'm living with my mom or
whatever and Angela I'll use me I feel
like everyone goes to the same [ __ ] yeah
I gotta that's a given if you're with a
man you're gonna be his mother
that's different
yup and then oh yeah I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] use a [ __ ] ILO Casey's a
[ __ ] girl I think she said it I
think this could work if the couple had
of a strong commitment to actually
making the relationship work out because
this like one or two night at a hotel
like it can probably really kickstart
it's just like a new beginning of like
oh yeah we've got to focus on us like on
our relationship with each other versus
like nitpicking out like what we've all
done wrong or like whatever issues that
they have like maybe like this could
just open their eyes and then outside of
the hotel like they could do other
things together
remember we only used to be friends like
that yeah would you guys be down with
blind eating what I heard in our
restaurant dessert yeah yeah when you're
in the complete darkness tops talking
about it's just because you know like
you're talking about you know when you
get into the mundane and then you guys
talk about business and all that stuff
then like 90% of the conversations you
have with your significant other its
business based it's not romantic based
you're not really getting to know each
other you look at a lot of our
conversation like that and then it's
really nice when we have that one day
we're just talking like we're a couple
and so to get out of that Monday
sometimes even going to eat it's still
Monday because you didn't know what each
other's like and of course gonna eat
pieces I'm going to eat this wouldn't go
here so even trying to get out of the
mundane you're still kind of in the
mundane but what if you go eat at a
place that's kind of like omakase except
it's not it's not a structured course
you both don't know what the about you
don't know where you're gonna eat you
get to be surprised yeah it could be
like one thing is like two spoonfuls of
sushi the next one is two spoonfuls of
pasta the next one or two that should
care doctors I have no other ones like
half a hotdog yeah random stuff and
always cut like that court that meal
you're having if you don't know what's
coming next you come like a roller
coaster and there's random things and
now you guys have a lot of stuff to talk
about because it's so random it could be
[ __ ] duck slippers I feel like it's a
good idea because you you it's like when
you're on a date or when you're
someone brand-new everything is fresh
and new so you're willing to go outside
of your comfort zone because you're
exploring together when you're in a
relationship for a long time I think
you're a lot of people maybe they don't
explore enough they they just want to do
what they're comfortable with they're
not exploring together anymore yeah hey
create the mundane because then you're
yeah if you explore together you're
experiencing new stuff together
but for some odd reason the longer
you're with the least you want to
explore because it becomes stressful
yeah now you want to go eat at the same
place you ate three thousand times rate
yeah that's cool it's probably because
it's hectic so when you do have that
time you just want to do something
comfortable mmm but it's not too much
thinking it's kind of like being angry
you're not trying to look for a new
experience you just want to eat what
you're used to mm-hmm we should just put
on orange jumpsuits and leather on the
outside of a kale sure that's okay new
that's a new experience just put you
inside if you do with the guards to
thank you first see what the guards are
doing up like standing on top yeah not
an actual prison thing but I could see
your concept is like turning new things
and I'm like that's fun you should try
and just running around I'm skint I
c-can't the orange jumpsuit I have to
tell your dad shot by sniper you know I
wouldn't do that your baby might be
taken away because I love Triana and I
said not the prison thing but the idea
that I something new I like that oh yeah
like you could wear like a bear outfit
and go into the forest where it when
it's hunting
yeah well no one gets hurt no one goes
to jail how about something like that
but I guess I put barbecue sauce on your
hand they stick it in lion's cage oh no
count me out hey guys how did you guys
like that JK news episode well let us
know by liking the video for more videos
click right over here
[Music]